[Applause]
it's not every day that you'll see an
amputee walking along with a peg leg and
then begin to tap dance
[Music]
my name is evan ruggiero and i am a
one-legged tap dancer
it's fun i started tap dancing when i
was six years old
it's something that i fell in love with
i knew that tap dancing would always be
something that i wanted to do for the
rest of my life
when i was 19 years old i had a pain in
my right leg
i was diagnosed with osteosarcoma bone
cancer and on
may 21st 2010 i had my right leg
amputated above the knee
[Music]
i was devastated
i just thought how could a tap dancer be
diagnosed with cancer in his leg
i remember my tap teacher showing me
footage of peg leg baits who was a great
tap dancer way back in the day you know
had it not been for that footage i would
have never thought that i could tap
dance again
[Music]
when i put that peg leg on for the first
time and i started making those rhythms
i felt a part of me that came back and i
felt like my old self
i was able to teach myself how to dance
again i just let muscle memory kick back
in and i tried not to think about making
a step pop step with my peg leg but just
peg hot peg and changing around the
vocabulary of the step
i perform in new york city
there's definitely been an audible gasp
in the audience once or twice while i
walk out on stage
[Applause]
tap dancing isn't very personal
it's very much about the emotion
a lot of times you can tell when a tap
dancer is happy by the way he's dancing
despite having a diagnosis with cancer i
was able to overcome that and i was able
to go back to the things that i love the
most so it's always going to be a very
different emotion that is tied to the
art form
[Applause]
[Music]
you